[Music]
so yesterday the word
obesity was trending on twitter for now
from what i can tell
the reason for this trend was at least
apart the announcement from krispy kreme
that they're going to give you free
donuts well free doughnuts actually
multiple fruit
if you can produce proof that you were
vaccinated for coven
so not just one donut they'll give you a
free donut every day for the rest of the
year
now will anyone actually take them up on
this i mean will anyone bring
their medical paperwork into a krispy
kreme shop every day
for a year to get a free donut well
anyone will anyone get the vaccine just
just for the free donuts i don't know
but if i know anything about americans
the answer is
certainly yes now keep one thing in mind
though
krispy kreme is known for reneging on on
these kinds of promises
there was a time many moons ago when you
could go into a krispy kreme store
anytime the hot now light was on and you
could get a free donut
if the sign said hot now um and there
was a time many moons ago when i would
often take advantage
of that perk but then and i like to
think this is thanks exclusively to my
own
uh gluttonous and greed they stopped
offering the free donuts
at least the krispy kremes were around
where i lived that was the case
so now um hot now only means that the
donuts are hot and fresh which of course
means that when the light isn't on
they aren't hot and fresh and that's a
problem because krispy kreme donuts
are exceptional in that they are the
only food item which goes from being
heavenly
as soon as it emerges from the oven to
inedible four minutes later
the donuts are great when they're piping
hot but downright reprehensible at room
temperature
the second law of thermodynamics has not
been kind to krispy kreme
anyway i seem to have lost the plot
somewhere
uh the the point is that krispy kreme is
trying to help fight covet by giving out
donuts and this is potentially doing
more harm than good
seeing as obesity as one of the major
coveted risk factors
one of the reasons that coveted hit us
so hard is that we have so many obese
people in this country it doesn't seem
like a great idea in light of that fact
to encourage even more obesity
and it is that word obesity which
prompted this tweet from actress jamila
jamil
um known for her role in that one show
uh and also that other show
and oh yeah that did you ever see that
thing about the person
doing the thing she's in that too i
think well she whoever she is she she
tweeted this
she said quote obesity trending opens
the floodgates to a tsunami of ignorant
and illogical abuse against the fat
community
lacking context nuance and humanity
below is something i want you to
understand
and then there's a picture with even
more text presumably written by her
saying quote obesity is trending on the
subject of obesity and the amount of
people who die allegedly from it
allegedly from it i think it's important
to keep reminding people that
a lot of fat people die or become
seriously ill because their symptoms of
serious illness are ignored by doctors
who blame everything on their weight and
therefore don't investigate their health
properly
cancer cysts respiratory brain tumors
life-threatening gynecological issues
etc
often missed by practitioners who are
unable to see past their own
fat phobia so until people who are
larger than average are treated equally
by doctors
and not dismissed and dehumanized so
pervasively and frequently we can't have
an informed or fair conversation about
any death
rates or health issues related to
obesity
okay now where to start maybe with this
she refers to the number of people who
die allegedly from obesity
for the record as far as that number
goes 78 percent of people hospitalized
with covet in the u.s were overweight or
obese
worldwide according to the world health
organization 2.8 million people die from
obesity
related causes each year and that's
pre-coveted those are the pre-coveted
numbers 2.8 million
worldwide it's only gotten worse not
better
jamil mentions that obese people die
from cancer
cysts respiratory issues which are
allegedly missed by the fat phobic
doctors well it turns out that
obesity increases your risk of
developing all of those things
the doctors are not ignoring those
health concerns hazards by telling you
to get your weight under control
they're telling you to get your weight
under control because of those hazards
and countless others we see here the
extent to which the words like
words like equality and bigotry have
lost their coherence
the words quite literally don't mean
anything anymore you may as well not
say them because nobody will know what
you mean when you do
no doctors should not treat obese people
equal to other people
because they're not equal if you're
obese
you are less healthy more at risk more
likely to die
and doctors absolutely ought to be
taking that into account
asking for a doctor to treat fat people
equally is like complaining
when your allergist gives you and gives
you an inhaler
because people without asthma don't need
inhalers so you're being treated
unequally
well you gave me an inhaler what about
him why don't you give him one
well because he doesn't have asthma you
dope
you you are as a person with asthma you
are unequal
to non-asthma people unequal as in not
the same as
you are different you have this risk
factor and they don't
is your doctor being asthma phobic by
giving you that inhaler
i suppose so yeah he is he is rightly
afraid of what asthma might do to you
and so he's trying to treat it in the
same way it is right to be afraid
of what obesity might do to a person fat
phobic
sure i'm fat phobic i announce it
proudly i
am fat phobic i don't want to be fat
myself
i don't want my loved ones to be fat i
don't want anyone to be fat
i am i am phobic of that i am phobic of
people being fat
the reason i don't want that for myself
or for anyone else is that i don't want
to die
i don't want anyone else to die being
fat not only can kill you
but it will it will there's a reason why
you rarely see morbidly obese 80 year
olds
the reason is that obesity will shorten
your lifespan you're straining your body
and your internal organs by carrying
around
all that extra baggage eventually your
body and your organs will be taxed to
their limits
this is the reality it's not pleasant
but that doesn't make it not real
so for all these extraordinarily obvious
reasons the idea of fat acceptance the
idea that there
you know even is such a thing as the fat
community which we must afford rights
and equality to
if you think about that fat community
it's utter incomplete madness
yet it's predictable madness in a
culture where self-love is not only the
highest love but indeed the only love we
recognize we are encouraged to
focus our sights inward right to value
our emotional well-being above all else
to put
to put ourselves before everything and
everyone to recognize
no moral law but our own whims
we've seen the catastrophic consequences
of living in a civilization that
operates that way
and we've seen in many forms the great
irony
which is that we focus the more we focus
on ourselves the more we demand
acceptance of ourselves and of our vices
the more we love ourselves in this way
the more damage we do to ourselves
we are loving ourselves to death you
might say
even death by krispy kreme and other
assorted
junk foods and for that reason jamila
jamil
whoever she is and all the other
apostles from the church of fat
acceptance
all must be forthwith cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated